[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
make way for the number two overall pick
in this past year's draft out of
michigan aidan hutchinson
and uh fritzy says that i have to bring
up call of duty uh so let me start there
aiden uh how important is call of duty
to your life
yeah i mean call of duty it's always
been something where um it's been
something where i i can i come off
practice and you know you just want to
uh you know just just just get online
with your friends and and kind of get
away from a little bit from all the
stress of football and everything like
that so i think
um that's the biggest that's the biggest
thing that call of duty has helped me
with is really just uh you know allowing
me to find a way to to to get away from
from from the stressful life and just
just play some video games with my
friends
but
how important is it if i said you could
go out on a date
or you could play
call of duty
well
uh i guess it would depend it would
depend on who you know i have a
girlfriend we're taking no dates right
now so i'm i'm taking the call of duty
okay okay what oh okay so you've already
established that you have a girlfriend
so you don't have to worry about that
but if she said hey let's go to dinner
and you said
i gotta get treatment even though
your treatment is call of duty
yeah you know that is where you got to
make a decision and i think you know it
it depends on where you're going depends
it depends on the importance obviously
if it's a anniversary or something we
can't miss those but you know if it's a
casual dinner you know we might might
just have to get online with some of the
boys and and you know call it a call it
a recovery night so you know we'll see
uh the strangest thing you ever heard
from jim harbaugh was what
strangest thing i've ever heard
um or that he did
you know i think
uh
i think
every day when we were going out to
practice i wouldn't call this strange
but um well
you take it how you want it but um you
know
every day when we go out to practice he
would be you know um doing his little
pre-practice lifts and he would uh he
was always
you know going really hard in the squat
rack and some days he would actually um
you know have his shirt off in the
weight room you know as all the guys are
getting ready to go out there you know
you see coach harbaugh you know kind of
with his shirt off and his khakis on and
his cleats you know just ripping out
some squats in the weight room so i
think consistently seeing those things
and then that's normal to me now you
know just because i was around it for so
long so i think uh
that that that's just those are just
kind of the day in the life things that
you get but i could see coach campbell
doing that now
coach campbell yeah he's uh he's it's a
it's a different
it's i don't know if i could see coach
campbell doing that i mean he's coach
campbell will rip out some down ups with
with uh with with the boys but i don't
know if i could if i see him shirt off
squat in the weight room you know he's
the he's the he's pretty humble with
with the you know how how built he is so
well he says he's a big guy
he's huge yeah he's ginormous yeah okay
when he gets mad or when harbaugh gets
mad
who would make you a little more nervous
um
it's a little different with both of
them especially now being in the nfl
it's um you know obviously when you're
in college it's a little bit different
you know you got a bunch of young guys
um you're around a bunch of young guys
who don't really know a whole lot and
you go to the nfl the coaching's a
little bit different and you know
the um
you know when you when you get yelled at
it's a little bit different because
you're with dudes who are some of them
are older than some of our coaches so
it's just it's a i i don't know if i can
compare because i think it's a different
kind of uh
it's different uh you know chemistry or
with the player to coach relationships
yeah harbaugh i well i think both might
border on being crazy
but in a good way
because you know watching hard knocks
like i i'd play for campbell like oh
yeah sign me up i come oh yeah i think
anybody anybody would you know i can't
play but i would play i'd certainly i'd
certainly i'd run through i'd run
through a screen door for him not a wall
like a like a lightly built screen door
i think i could do that and then when
you had to get up and do your billie
jean dance
um i i i liked it a lot of props and it
felt like uh
you uh you distinguished yourself as had
a little bit of rhythm there how how
nervous were you when you had to perform
in front of the vets
yeah i mean that was a moment that i i
saw coming for a while but i didn't know
when when judgment day was and you know
it was really in that meeting that was
uh that was i mean when you guys heard
it in hard knocks that was when i you
know that's when i realized in real time
like i was doing this thing right right
here right now so
did you rehearse
oh yeah i had to i didn't know the
lyrics at all when i picked the song
because i know that i knew the chorus
but nobody knows what he says like you
know and the verse is leading up to it
you're kind of just popping to it and so
uh i had to study those so i was
studying those lyrics and meetings and
stuff in my head i was always rehearsing
them just for the moment that
that that moment would come so
um i i had to study a lot a lot on top
of football it was a little bit
stressful but i'm glad it's over with
well plus it was televised
and you know that's different from a lot
of other rookies hard knocks is there
so they're covering it and then all of a
sudden you know i don't know if that
starts to sink in like
god everybody can see this if they want
to see this
oh yeah and i'm and i'm not someone who
uh i'm not someone who was about to get
up there and get booed either so i
wanted to go up there i wanted to do a
little performance i wanted i wanted to
uh you know just just sell out and i
knew that if i went up there had a good
song and i really just gave it my own
you know i think the the boys would like
it a little bit so it worked out what
did uh mom or your sister say
they loved i didn't even tell them that
i was doing the song i came home one day
and i was like i did it i'm done i did
my rookie song and it's out the way and
they were uh i didn't even tell them you
know i didn't tell them i was picking
billie jean or any of that so they were
they were relieved for me because
because my mom knew how you know you you
know how stressful it is just being a
rookie having to do a lot of rookie
things get you out of your comfort zone
so yeah you didn't get stuck with the
dinner bill yet did you
it's coming
it's coming and we will see i don't i i
think we got some good vets in the room
so i don't think hopefully it's not too
high but i know it's coming
because it might be 20 grand
it might be but there's also a second
round pick
josh pascal so we're gonna we're gonna
split it so it'll be all right wait no
you make more money than he do you can't
split it
yeah well you know he's he's making
second-round money
hey that's not top five pick money
you're right you're right but you know
everyone's gotta pay their rookie dudes
in some way uh do you hate ohio state
that's a
it's an interesting question dan um you
know
i certainly don't like them okay um
hatred uh i don't know i don't i don't
hate a whole lot of things but
um
i
i don't like them at all and i never
will so call that what you want but yeah
do you have any friends who went to ohio
state
um could you be friends with somebody
who went to ohio state
i have no friends before the lions
on ohio state but now that i'm on the
lions um
there's a couple buckeyes in there
buckeye grads and you know we don't talk
about it but it's okay
and uh you know that's fine and
um yeah i didn't know them during their
ohio state days and now our paths have
crossed so um it will have to do and
those are my teammates now you're the
only michigan guy i think on the roster
i got three ohio state guys here
yeah i know it's it's it's tough
sledding but you know come come uh
whenever they plan november november
yeah come november we'll be uh we'll be
putting some money down for sure i like
that i like and you got bragging rights
at least up until then because oh yeah
you guys dominated
for sure for sure but those guys in that
locker room they
they they beat they beat us when we were
there some of those older guys so
that they don't feel my glory like i do
but
it's all good
hey good luck with uh coming up you got
the commanders and uh thanks for joining
us on behalf of call of duty
yeah thanks thanks dan thanks for having
me that's aidan hutchinson and the lions
are favored against the commanders first
time that's happened in over two years
are you happy i got to uh call the duty
there for sure all right give it a lot
of love thank you